[Musique]
oubliez les gestes
hier yves hier après-midi ce parc
parisien ressembler à une discothèque en
plein air plus d'une centaine de
personnes se sont rassemblées pour faire
la fête
en dépit des mesures sanitaires en panne
avec le leader un peu de gens se
rappellent des souvenirs d'avant d'avant
que le vide
ça remonte un peu le moral on me suis
pas du tout inquiet par les images que
jouer aux buttes-chaumont un récent
papier qui est sorti dans la grande
revue lancet qui dit la contamination
par ce virus là elle se fait
essentiellement par l'air et les
physiciens vous disent que si c'est une
contamination par l'air elle ne peut pas
avoir les lieux en extérieur en platon
finement ces images ont suscité
l'indignation
c'est un peu avant l'heure du couvre-feu
de la sécurité du parc est intervenue
pour mettre fin à la fête alors pour
qu'on nous impose port du masque depuis
maintenant de longs mois à l'extérieur
contre quel que soit d'ailleurs le
respect parce qu'on n'ose pas se dédire
quand vous avez obligé les gens à porter
pendant un an un masque en extérieur
vous vous prépariez l'opinion avant de
leur dire que finalement ça servait à
rien c'est une bataille bien réel qui a
eu lieu samedi dans un parc du nebraska
une bagarre générale à coups de frites
de piscines où tous les participants
s'appelait josh l'idée saugrenue a été
lancée l'an dernier sur les réseaux
sociaux par cet étudiant américain
le principe que tous les josh d'amérique
s'affrontent et que seul le vainqueur
puisse conserver ce prénom très répandue
outre atlantique
un événement bon enfant remporté par le
petit josh quatre ans qu'à chaque fois
que quelqu'un est contaminée et qui ne
se désole pas c'est comme s'il avait une
mitraillette et qui mitraillaient les
gens autour de lui donc c'est c'est
gravissime doivent c'est la terminale et
300 morts par jour à chaque fois qu'il
ya quelqu'un était positif qui a des
symptômes et qu'il ne s'isole pas ils
contaminent d'autres personnes qui vont
peut-être mourir et qui vont peut-être
faire mourir d'autres
vous pensez que le comité d'un manteau
partir écoute je pense pas qu'il va
partir du jour au lendemain
la question c'est est ce qu'on va
réussir à réduire les gens qui va
diminuer le nombre de gens qui pour
certains en meurent pour d'autres sont
très malades à cause de lui c'est pour
ça qu'on fait qu'on a toutes ces
contraintes que l'on dise aux jeunes
qu'il faut pas qu'ils se rassemblent mai
que mai et oui qu'on les enferme pendant
deux ans est absolument dans les
affaires que j'ai un style aujourd'hui
avec justin
un couvre-feu 19h l'été c'est beaucoup
plus difficilement supportable qu'un
couvre-feu à 19h en février bon c'est
vraiment intéressant
non mais je sais que vous avez je
remercie de cette on va le mettre à 21h
je vous remercie vraiment s'appuyer sur
vire
tu as aimé
oui oui vous avez été inspiré par la
nouvelle idée de marlène schiappa la
ministre qui suggère que le débat
d'entre deux tours à la présidentielle
2022 soit animé par cyril hanouna
mais oui ma petite beauté c'est la
spécialité de main à l'ancien pas
propositions sorties du chapeau la
petite phrase qui suscite un tollé sur
les réseaux cette fois vous avez mal
même dossier du monde qui commence en
disant c'est un animal qui a été nourri
à la politique et c'est vrai et vous
l'avez prouvé dans l'émission et moi
c'est ça qu'on attend vous allez
effectivement à lier tous les publics
vous emmène pas du tout alors je
l'écoutais tous les publics et je suis
sourd que j'ai raison cela pour une fois
c'est plutôt d'accord avec reebok dans
le sens où je pose la question sur le
rapport à l'eau oui puisqu'il ira du
générique des zemmour applaudir sa pose
et oui c'est bien cru que quelqu'un qui
n'a rien gagné
quand tu n'as rien gagner laurent suis
levé mais ce n est pas un signe de
cadeaux de code social
jadore jadore jadore alors alors alors
le biniou rivière
[Musique]
c'est fragile
celle-ci resserré et vous n'êtes pas
absolument fan d'art contemporain bon on
peut dire que je suis championne en face
et je déteste la passante à 99% rien une
monstruosité de se mobiliser maintenant
aider c'est grandiose et vous est ce que
ça coûte très cher qui sont bluffés par
le pognon c'est au président ken
catherine on ne touche pas le cylindre
on met les doigts à l'intérieur oui
c'est les doigts un terreau midi devait
peut-être c'est un cylindre fragile ça
fait le deuxième quand alex fertile
partisans location et vous espèce de
truc ridicule de jeff koons cela dope
balloon ce qui se vend 50 3 millions de
dollars dès cet après midi là bas si je
trouve pas ça admirable c'est que je
suis arrêté si l'asie et à regarder dans
la musique à écouter de la musique
contemporaine
bah ça m'arrive à de petits boulots salt
un missile boulez mais difficile c'est
inaudible c'est pas du tout bon diffuse
alors attendez ça c'est pas sympa lève
mais après 50 ans il est new york ace et
piéger tout seul sur ce site de
rencontres pour draguer il aurait pu se
présenter comme un homme dans la force
de l'âge portant très bien le bandana
d'un non regardez ce qu'il a préféré
dire à une de ses prétendantes
j'ai envahi le capitole vous allez voir
il je suis même arrivé jusqu à ce titre
we all alors réponse laconique de
l'intéressé we are not match j'ai eu un
accès de lui faire écouter la musique
que j'ai créé pour elle
[Musique]
plutôt qu'un rendez vous elle a préféré
faire des captures d'écran appelé le fbi
les enquêteurs ont comparé sa photo de
profil sur ce site de rencontres avec
les images des émeutes du 6 janvier
bingo il a été identifié arrêté la
semaine dernière
mais qu'est ce qui te complexe là mes
cuisses qu'est-ce qu'elles ont plus âgés
ou prendre un exemple tout simple on est
en planque au vide et à la distanciation
socialement mes cuisses elles n'ont pas
la distanciation social ils sont
pourtant je n'étais pas prêt sont tout
le temps collée et sont toujours en
train de se faire des bisous
je t'ai femmes les zougois j'ai dû moi
aussi j'ai marché aux poissons dont jean
égalité et commençait déjà à vivre des
trucs un peu dégueu l'auteur nous avons
fait sens et on se marie par voyage de
noces
on est des adultes consentants on est
des adultes responsables
mais clairement oui j'ai pris des
réservations au bout d'un moment je
fabrique mes pilules
[Musique]